the premiere is happening it is here
best season ever I have been told by
Chris Harrison
by Rob Mills we're so excited Chris I'm
gonna start with you round six were you
surprised when you got the call and why
did they call you oh that's a great
question I wasn't actually surprised
okay I feel like I've always been in
contact with someone from the show yeah
stayed in touch and you know I was I was
in a time where was kind of exciting for
me to actually entertain the call so
here I am round six I mean you know
people talk about Nick Viall you're the
record holder yes Nick's got nothing on
I just interviewed Chris this morning
and I said tell me the biggest
transformation is this season and he
said you why did you say that well you
know Chris has known me since I was 25
years old yeah I'm 32 now and we've done
this all together ironically so you know
I think he's you seen me grow a little
bit over the years and it's it's also
hearing that did the show this time
around feel different for you it's
evolved a lot since you oh you were last
absolutely the show fell completely
different this time around you know
i-i've been disconnected from from the
franchise a little bit I haven't really
been watching too much I watched
re-season cuz he was on The Bachelorette
with me yeah I know so going into this I
didn't really know anybody I had low
expectations and I just want to get to
know everybody and it was great it's a
great way to go into interviews things
have to tune in and watch all right
we'll taste Shep you go on a date with
Blake and Blake has been dubbed by
multiple people the biggest F boy in
Paradise history so any regrets about
going on that date regrets no I don't
regret anything okay no I had a great
time what happens with you and Blake
you're gonna have to watch tonight to
find out is Blake the biggest deaf boy
in Paris I wouldn't go that far
you wouldn't know okay might see
something else I don't know oh well
things look like they get pretty bad for
Blake pretty quick we see that in the
trail
he's literally saying get me out of here
yeah there on the beach did you guys see
that he was really going through it that
much how did you interact with him and
were you like hey man chill out oh no he
was really struggling yeah he was
definitely stressed and you know being
around the guys often and and yeah he
needed he needed the shoulder a few
times that's for sure
Teesha you were at stagecoach that's now
in - stage boring uh-huh
all this stuff was happening with
Christina with Kailen stagecoach getting
a lot of PR out of ash what were you
seeing that at that time did you know
Blake was hanging out and talking to and
hooking up with Christina and Galen I
had no idea in fact I was with nine of
the other girls okay
um we were just there we had a house
ourselves we were just partying at
stagecoach and we happened to go to the
neon festival and lake was there with
even Colton Cassie and Kailyn was there
already
Ethan wasn't in our group but I don't
know we were just having fun so so were
you surprised when you learned all this
yeah I was like what is going on but I
was in the mix I guess okay well you
guys the taxa Blake send them support
while this is airing it looks like it's
gonna be rough friend yeah Blake lives
right down the street from me in Denver
so Demi we've seen in the trailers
brings the franchise's first ever queer
relationship which is awesome what was
that like for you guys to be a part of
the filming of that and that moment for
the show yeah no you know I'm just
really excited be part of dummy's
journey last question tisha you know our
girl Hannah you run Colt the season with
her yeah she's been through it these
past weeks I'm sane she asked Tyler for
a drink
he's now rumored to be dating Gigi Hadid
what do you think screw up by Tyler over
your thoughts
honestly rumored they probably had a
drink there themselves I don't really
know what they're doing exactly but I
would watch how I don't know to say how
I see you better watch out people are
watching they're everywhere
all I'm saying is Tyler wasn't Hannah's
first choice so Tyler can
I can do this thing yeah well he said it
et also spoke with tisha and Chris on
the red carpet that same evening where
they revealed even more about their time
in paradise well some more drama is
about to come out and it's gonna start
involving more people than just myself a
lot more Blake a lot more Blake and
there's a first for me
and I'm really excited for that I think
it's a really special moment that I
can't wait for everybody experience with
me but affecting that you just have to
tune in it's a good one to see there's
definitely a first for me as well this
is my sixth rodeo so it's a to have a
sapper still it's pretty amazing but
know a lot of drama the most traumatic
season I've ever been a part of so it's
good definitely a tune in and watch